people don't need to have any idea what
they're talking about they just know
that that's a trump card and usually
it's going to work occasionally it
doesn't work
as we saw last night on bill maher heidi
heitkamp the former senator
from north dakota not not
the brightest bulb in the pack there was
one time a friend of mine was
going down to to serve in congress and
uh we were talking to a long-standing
u.s
congressman and we asked hey what what
should you
what should we know about congress you
know what should we know about the halls
of congress
and this long-standing congressman whose
name i won't mention said well
you're going to be disappointed the iq
on average is not so high there
and heidi heitkamp in her comments last
night i think
proved this point though unfortunately
she's no longer in the senate
she went on bill maher's show and they
they were addressing my my colleague
here gina carano
the movie star and mma fighter and heidi
heitkamp just just casually just said
gina carano she's a she's a nazi
everybody knows that
i like this picture uh who was the woman
in the
mandalorian what did she do she liked
something she was a nazi
oh that's different right i'm thinking
of somebody well she's not a nazi
um she does hang with white supremacists
it's like a mel brooks does
yeah hangs with whites i suppose i'm now
get subject to defamation
i i don't know i mean it depends on what
your definition of white supremacist is
that you're
so the goal post there changed a lot of
guy in a clan hood who
but i think we have to i think we have
to be really careful there's two things
the republicans think they're going to
get biden on
cancel culture and this whole dr seuss
stuff that's going on where they're
reading
green eggs and ham proving that some of
these senators can actually read
and and um and and
immigration and and and so we can't
ignore the fact that we got donald trump
was in part because
of political correctness oh i hope gina
does sue her for defamation i i don't
think she will because defamation suits
are just really
really hard to win and you spend a lot
of money on lawyers in it if you're a
public figure it usually doesn't work
but i hope she does because
what heidi heitkamp here is saying is
just completely indefensible
and and worse than the slander of it all
is the laziness
to say this woman doesn't know a thing
about gina carano
this woman has probably never googled
gina carano
but she reads some facebook post
from i don't know her like blue haired
niece or something that said gina
carano's a nazi and that's all that's
all it takes
so yeah no she's a nazi and then bill
maher to his credit he goes a little
light on her but at least he calls her
out he says what
wait i think he thought she was kidding
at first he goes oh yeah yeah everyone's
a nazi wait are you really saying that
heidi wait you she's a nazi and then
heidi realizes
she's like uh oh i thought i could just
get away with this casual this drive-by
slander
now i'm being called out on it now i
actually have to defend my views but i
can't because i have no idea what i'm
talking about
oh and then she tries to dial it back so
she dials it back from nazi from
literally hitler to
well you know she but she's no she's a
white supremacist i'm not
yeah no oh yeah everyone knows that
right please let me get away with this
bill please wait
what euro she's how's she a white
supremacist and then bill tries to
dig her out of it a little bit he's like
well i guess it depends what
your definition of white supremacist is
but what how do you
and then then heidi tries to bring it
back even further he goes oh yeah no she
hangs
with white white supremacists and she uh
she uh uh who who what do you know about
anything heidi height nothing
and then the other guy who the
libertarian guy was named i forget at
the moment but he uh
he comes out he defends gina i think
quite well and says
no she just she compared the actions
of some other people to some actions
that the nazis did she
made a comparison she's not she didn't
even call anybody nazis and she
certainly if you accuse someone of being
a nazi as though that were a terrible
thing
you yourself probably wouldn't embrace
the label nazi right it's just so
stupid it's just so incredibly lazy
and then and then i love my the button
on the whole interview and she goes
yeah and no but bill you know hold on i
can't defend my views so
uh i think we need to be really careful
you need to be really careful you just
called a woman a nazi without any
evidence whatsoever
without knowing a thing about her and we
need to be careful and then she pivots
and tries to talk about something else
it's vermont she got caught in the way
it was
i keep going back to this because it was
so funny a black democrat lady called in
to david webb's radio show once and he
made a good point
and she said well you only think that
because of your white privilege and i
guess she didn't know
she never met david webb and so david
webb goes
ma'am i don't think you would say that
if you knew me she goes no you are it's
because you're white privileged david
webb of course is
very much a black man and uh so he goes
uh ma'am i'm
a black guy and she she says oh
okay well anyway you know i it doesn't
matter
it's not the claim the charge of white
supremacy or nazism or whatever
that's not the conclusion of an argument
that's the premise that's where that's
where they're starting from
and then if the premise is proven wrong
oh too bad or i will try something else
but usually they don't get called out on
the premises so they just get to
continue
the smears if you enjoyed that break
from disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video